thank you
good well first of all we officially
will do apologies for absence so it's
just one is that
uh yes councillor salt uh is not present
here
um do we need to do a roll call
um what we usually do suppose the issue
is
two new members although i think you've
actually seen beforehand and
the uh details are on the screen there
so if if members are comfortable then
you could just go straight on to
apologies for absence
i think we know everybody don't we
yeah yes yes it's just for anybody who's
live streaming you know it's just to
make sure that uh
we are here in terms of this chair all
the members are here
um uh in terms of if you move on to
apologies
uh the the only we've got an apology
from matt brown who's unable to attend
the meeting today
uh the officer from the joint ict
servers
okay thanks alan any declarations of
interest in items on the agenda
none have been received here no
okay so we'll move on to item three the
minutes of the last meeting
has everybody read the minutes um is
everybody happy with them do they want
to make any
changes or
they look nobody can i'll move them
thank you give me a second please
okay uh shall we vote my hands up
yes thank you chair
yes that's a unanimous chair good thank
you
item four is the quarterly report of the
joint ict service
uh quarter four 2020 to 21 january to
march 20 to 21
that's pages 7 to 30 um in the pack
um can would you ask yourself you're
reporting please nikki
uh yeah uh hello welcome everybody
um just wanted to provide a summary of
the quarterly service report for the
joint ict
um service for cod 4 which covers
the period of january this year to the
end of march
most of you will be familiar with the
format and then we've got uh councillor
parking and council kenyan have
joined us recently and so i'll just go
over an overview really without uh
going into too much detail for you but
obviously
ask questions as and when you when you
would like
um the first two graphs show the number
of service requests and incidents that
the services received over the quarter
key points to note with this is that the
total number of incidents and service
requests
raised remained high throughout the
quarter
the trend is decreasing slightly
the service is receiving on average 10
additional calls per month compared to
the pre
figures and this is down from 18
which was seen in the increase from last
quarter
the next two graphs show the number of
outstanding calls uh these are ones that
are yet to be resolved
key points to note on this are is that
the total number of outstanding calls
has remained consistently high
over the past three months we've
generally seen the highest
some focus has been put on resolving
outstanding calls to bring this back
down to levels
um back down but the levels are still
remain high
the majority outstanding calls are
service requests rather than incidents
so they're sort of more lengthy requests
rather than
incidences that we
her interaction um due to continually
high numbers of calls since the coveted
outbreak
it's likely to take some time to reduce
the outstanding call list to the
pre-covered levels
and as predicted this is impacting the
sla in some way
this is as older calls get resolved
there will be an increase in percentages
of calls which will fail the sla
the next graph shows the first key
performance indicator
it shows the number of incidents all
service requests that are closed within
the target time
as anticipated there were some breaches
to the sla seen in february
due to the increased workloads and the
impact of resolving outstanding calls
however there was no breaches in january
and march
the two breaches in february saw that
bolsonaro was just under by three
percent
at the target and northeast at 10
the sla target for first time fixed
resolutions um was exceeded throughout
the quarter
moving on to outages section this is
where we report on major outages
which were classed as priority one which
has an impact on staff from across the
authority
such as a network outage or priority two
incidents which impacts multiple users
of the department
and for example the finance application
going down
we had two priority one incidents one in
january which was a short internet
outage of less than two hours
and one in march which was a telephony
issue at polls over
we diagnose each of these incidents we
make recommendations and implement any
actions to prevent future
outages or to improve our response to
these outages
onto projects during ict project time
is still high over the last quarter as
all authorities are similar
facing similar challenges for example
work on security improvements not
created major systems
it's done on all three authorities
um the percentage time spent on projects
was on average
above the 35 target during quarter four
and the full project register can be
seen in appendix 2 and i have
highlighted a summary of some of the
major projects
on the quarterly service report
uh next go on to the joint ic2 budget
for the financial year 2021
and that's shown on the report um
the joint ict service budget or zunda
spent
last financial year by just under 80 000
pounds the reasons for this were due to
delays in in due to internal
recruitments
and the termination payment was
completed early due to legislative
changes
and there was a vacant 0.5 service desk
post
also reduced travel costs due to agile
working
vacant senior application developer
posts and
the income the variable income that we
get from overtime costs which are built
to the appropriate authority
um i would like to ask the committee
members to recommend what happens to the
underspend
and we normally do this at the end of
end of the year
and the options being option one return
the proportionate
underspend back to each authority or
option two would be to reinvest the
money back into the joint ict service
the percentages and amounts this equates
to for each authority are shown on the
report
so for instance for north east it's it's
36
000 just over 36 000 for falls over
it's just over 26 thousand
and for derbyshire dolls it's um just
over 16 000.
my recommendation would be to reinvest
the money back into the service
for the following reasons to assist with
microsoft 365 project rollout
the microsoft 365 project requires much
resource
to be dedicated to it to implement the
rollout successfully
and in a timely manner to all three
authorities
we're recovering from the additional
demands placed on the service due to
coving 19 and the requirement to work
in a more agile way we would therefore
like to consider using some of the
underspend to invest in consultancy or
temporary resources to assist with
microsoft 365 project
um also we would like to invest in
products and services which will enhance
the security of the ict services
cyber security is an ever-increasing
threat to local authorities
the resources required to manage these
threats is increasing and with new ways
of working rapidly introducing its code
with lockdown
the service would like to look to invest
in new products or services to enhance
the security platform
and where possible reduce officer
resources transits to these products
as all three councils face similar
challenges the reinvestment proposals
aboard
above will be expected to be
proportional to the number of people
being supported
and therefore it would make sense to
approach it as a joint investment from
the joint ict budget rather than
individual client budgets any additional
proposals
investor money would be brought to the
committee for recommendation before
pursuing
therefore i would like to
like the committee members to advise
which option they would recommend
either option one return the
proportionate under spend back to the
authority
or option to reinvest the money back
into the service
i don't know the chairman that we
reinvest it i mean
you know it only saves the paid time
next time okay
keep it in uh do we have a second for
that
i'll second that sure uh thank you kevin
uh karen can i ask you a question um
this refund we were expecting that
dubs dale's have you got that in your
budget
yes no we haven't budgeted for anything
to be returned
and it would be a bonus and i would
support um
option two if i was asked
okay that that's to retain it's leave it
in the uh yeah
okay good well i think we should um
shall we have a vote on that alan yes
chair if
members are comfortable with that can it
be just hands up or do you want to go
around each
so again just to be clear that the
motion is is that the uh underspent
should be reinvested in the joint ict
service with any specific proposals
then being brought back to the committee
for consideration before a final
agreement by the uh host councils is
that the
essence of nikki that's it yeah yeah
i do if you agree with the two first two
proposals it's just that if i wouldn't
want to sort of delay it
um if we were to invest it in the
microsoft 365 project or in a security
product
um i mean i'm happy you know i can if i
can send it by email i'm not sure what
the procedure is
if i can send it by email and everybody
approves it then
fine yeah nikki can i ask
you how much of the 79 000 would would
be needed for that
i'm not totally sure i wouldn't expect
for
we're actually in speaking to vendors at
the moment
to find out what the increased cost will
be
for the security that we need and
regarding the
microsoft 365 i think it would cover
it would be enough to cover it but i can
always come back
later if that's if that's where you
prefer to to do it
yes i think i think that would be best
yeah
okay so we've been moved and seconded so
uh
we'll have a vote is it vote by hands
alan i think so chief members are
comfortable with that
so this is voting for
that is a unanimous chair
good thank you well thanks for that
nikki are there any questions
other questions for nikki please
yes chair i'd i'd like to just ask a
question if that's okay
that's fine yeah um nikki um
and looking at the uh the call uh the
response figures and the
uh and the charts uh it occurs to me
that
the agile working of the staff during uh
during lockdowns and agile working shall
we say
may have impacted and the type of calls
you're getting
but also being impacted by the fact that
we are using agile working
are you able to attribute any of those
extra calls that you might have received
from
home workers shall we call them
to uh to any of the blips in the chart
um in what in relation to what i'm not
quite sure which blips do
are you referring to okay so the the
february
the february rise in particular uh the
rising calls then
not that i'm aware of um it would we
have to scrutinize it quite often when
we when we look at the
rising calls and we don't normally see a
pattern
um relating to anything specific
as far as i'm aware there was nothing
specific that was rolled out
differently at that period of time yeah
in many ways that's a relief nikki thank
you
uh get uh gary i see you've got your
hand up have you got a question
i was going to move it but um stephen
let me do it
yeah okay uh i can't see any other hands
out are there any more questions
for nikki no
doesn't seem so good well thanks very
much nikki
and very full full report um
i've just got a couple more bits to go
through if that's okay sorry
um i thought it was appropriate for me
to mention that uh
that recommendation whilst we were
talking about the budget
um there's just a couple of bits i'll
just go through i won't keep too long
cost saving plan nothing's changed on
there we've got a couple of things
some northeast we can reduce the cost
through sip
um moving from the more expensive is the
end to the sip
lines for the telephony um at the moment
it's been delayed a little bit because
of resources and also because it's
dependent on all the projects such as
new firewall and um the internet link
um there's also the intellect link which
will
reduce the same resulting some
savings but not till later on in the
year
um security port report there was
nothing um
no reportable security incidents logged
um
i can provide an update on the phishing
training exercise which
we spoke about last year um but it had
to be
postponed due to the impact of covid and
we have the technical infrastructure set
up we are managing some
campaigns at the moment and hopefully
i'm expecting that i can bring an update
to the committee
um on the next quarter
on how successful it was etc
um in the meantime we continue to
provide additional training or send out
emails when we become aware of specific
targeted phishing attacks that come
through
service development um despite the
additional demands placed on the service
since last march
the feedback from user group service
managers and senior management
has been very positive and complementary
the bi-annual joint
ict user survey was conducted at the
beginning of this year
and the overall user satisfaction
results were all about it
above 80 the 80 target
they're showing at the bottom of the
report and so for bowls over
we got 85 percent overall satisfaction
derbyshire dells was 97
northeast 96 and mignolet homes 90
this is fantastic achievement
considering the challenges we've been
faced
um since march last year and a lot and
the large-scale changes that we've had
to make on how people use
technology which has enabled many roles
to effectively work remotely
i think this is credit to the dedication
of the team and they have ensured that
we've been able to provide an excellent
service
we'll we're going to collate all the
responses from the user survey to
develop a user
survey action plan and that will be used
to continue to improve
the service further that's it from me
thank you uh thanks so much nikki i'll
ask you again are there any more
questions about the second
part of nikki's presentation
counselor kenyon's indicating chair okay
canyon i just asked uh is the
recruitment still on hold
for the and if so why for that developer
and that's christian's post so christian
unfortunately kristen is not here at the
moment i think there was
um some hr issues with it
and but i'd have to get back with the
proper answer because it's uh
it's not not the post that in my team
i'll choke christian thanks yeah it may
be that i may have
worded it slightly it might not be that
it's on hold it's there's something
that's holding it up
um i can't see any more hands up are
there any more questions
for nikki no it sounds not
well thanks again nikki i'm sorry for
cutting you off no no
thank you all um right so the next item
urgent items alan have we got anything
hello
coming in uh i've been having trouble
logging in
and he keeps going back out so if i
disappear i'm having a little problem
okay thanks thanks for having us now
so we're urgent items alan did you say
that i've not received any chair
no okay so the last item is the dates
time for next meeting
have we got a date in yet we've sent
some me
to apologize there uh we sent some
meeting requests around
and i think the first one that you
should receive would be for the
fifth of july uh which would then be the
annual general meeting
of the committee okay
so we changed chair then don't we
yeah at that point uh north east
derbyshire would uh
take the chair and um bolsova would be
the
uh vice chair nominee now um as members
of the were the
um positions going to change in terms of
virtual meetings so as things stand
we'd be we're looking to arrange that
meeting uh as a
physical meeting uh at one of the three
councils
now if you remember prior to the covert
lockdown
um the pattern was is that we would
actually hold it
um basically in rotation at each of the
councils
i would suggest well i think that the
next one on the list
will be there's been a year's gap on
that will be bolsover would members be
comfortable with that again we would
need to actually
check the availability of the chamber
and such like matters
sorry chair councillor kenyon's
indicating uh yeah
yeah counselor sorry thank you um the
um and we you might have had this
discussion in the previous meeting about
do we want to try to continue with
virtual meetings and
my personal conference will be mostly
yes
with the occasional physical meeting um
but um as i understand it it would have
to be an informal meeting unless they
changed legislation
and i just wonder what's the what's the
number of
meetings that we formally have to have
as a board
is it well at the moment i
think actually um the committee decided
it wanted four meetings during the
course of the year but that's
could be changed i think the only thing
that you really need to do would be to
have an annual meeting
yeah so the next meeting
is the it's two o'clock on the fifth
yeah is that right
on the fifth um
uh ball's over
yeah sure can i just touch on the
virtual meeting
point cancel the kenyans raised yeah um
the appeal was lost um and the fact is
that
they've dictated that governments have
got to provide primary legislation
for any future virtual meetings so as
you touched upon the only
way you could have virtual meetings is
informally
we've chosen not to do that at dubstalls
because
we didn't feel it gave any benefit it
doesn't get a decision out
and so we've gone delegated and
we're very very hopeful that the
infections won't rise in this country
but i think we have to give a caveat but
we have to watch that situation
i mean again i think we need to uh
discuss outside of the meeting in terms
of
of the wider um response to uh the
development
but i mean it would be possible because
this
happens in other bodies where we would
actually just go
and become an informal meeting and the
quarterly service report and any other
issues were dealt with that way
um that obviously means that you
wouldn't actually um
be able to take formal decisions but we
would in those circumstances still be
able
to report back what your views were
yeah is that okay gary yes fine i mean
it's down to
joint decision of course um but yeah
just doing our perspective
and there's a situation that will change
i'm sure
yes jim you're absolutely right that is
still a goodly way before the um
the annual meeting so um we'll be
further in touch with members on this
yeah well i mean this is july the 5th so
i think it's a date in june isn't it
where the
the restrictions cease to apply i
believe that's the 21st of june chair
yeah so it could be okay for a physical
one then
but yeah council is trying to pretend
councillor is trying to get your
attention
counseling we can't speak yeah basically
it's just a question
with respect to venues um before
we we actually went on lockdown um
we were having problems at northeast
derbyshire in particular
uh with the with the sound in the
in the council chamber um and i
requested at that time that
we actually conduct the the meetings
in a a position where maybe i can hear
on this situation i can hear pretty much
perfectly if if everybody sort of
sort of keeps in line in only one
speaking at once
but if if we do go back into uh meeting
up
uh in in situ can you tell me alan as
the as the
surround sound or the sound system being
altered at northeast i understood
that it was in the process but i've
heard nothing about it since
yes i understand it chair there were
some improvements which were in the
pipeline um obviously i think
they may have gone on hold um as a
consequence of the
of the pandemic and essentially sort of
the closed down of meetings
i'll get that check but i would have
thought that in in the first
instance if we were to have um holy
physical meetings
if the first of the meetings was to be
at uh ball so
over assuming it's available then
perhaps also then
at a northeast if that was available
that would mean that the third meeting
was later in the year
at northeast derbyshire at which point
hopefully uh the improvements will be
well and truly made
so if members are comfortable with that
okay
good so we've got the dating time fixed
and we'll we'll find out later whether
it's
or another method off virtual so that's
the end of the agenda
thank you very much thank you for your
presentation thank you for counsellors
for attending and uh
participating and thanks alan very
exciting
thank you good night yes
you